hello everyone I promise to show you
another game from round 12 so here it is
decided it's best to do it immediately
as it is Saturday you know there's still
time to go grab a nice beer so here we
have it ocular mom in general versus
Bingley Ren also a clash of titans as
neither neither short nor ding have lost
a single game yet so of course it's it's
definitely a very interesting matchup
and I told you in my previous video that
I didn't get any photos from Nikki from
the previous round she did take some
photos so she forgot to upload them
unfortunately so here are some of them
this is a position from from the
previous game kurakin versus Caruana
here we have also the final photo of
that game the handshake
we're sorry Kerrigan takes the lead in
the tournament and we also have some
photos from this round here is mamud yar
of ready for war here we have ding Liron
also pondering over the position also a
very nice photo and here maybe even my
favorite follow from this round such a
glitch to be just strolling around as I
don't know how many of you have seen the
environment these guys are playing in
but there are like four little cubicles
and you know players are a player's can
stroll around and I've seen photos from
every round this is round twelve and
whenever I see photos freaked taken from
above it's always such a grease Chuck
who's walking around checking out other
people's positions so definitely
definitely an interesting fact but ok
let's see this game Madara has the white
pieces and he opens with d4 we have
Knight to f6 c4 e6 so this could be a
lot of things Knight to f3 and of course
d5 always transposing into the Queens
gambit declined Knight to c3 c5 now and
C captures on d5 the semi Taurus
Knight captures on d5 efore now Knight
captures big captures on c3 see
character C captures and Bishop to b4
check Bishop to d2 and I think there
already was a one game played in this
variation I just
can't remember in which round it was
Bishop captures Queen captures and now
castles Bishop to c4 Knight to d7 mama D
our of castles and now b6 preparing to
develop the light square Bishop rook a
to d1 worship to b7
we have rook to e1 and now rook the c8
attacking that Bishop Bishop to b3 rook
to e8 and h3 now Knight to f6 with a
double attack on that a pawn Queen to f4
defending the pawn and now knife to h5
and now what do you do with the Queen
here obviously you can go back to where
you came from you could maybe do what
mama did he played Queen - H - Queen -
g4 seems like a very active square but
the Queen to g4 is basically a draw
invitation here ding would reply Knight
to f6 and then basically we just have to
go back it's hard to say if Knight h5
was played by doing which the idea of
draw draw drawing this game early as
mama tiara wasn't I don't know if he
would enjoy a hand roll with the white
pieces this early I seriously doubt it
but it definitely forces him to do
something so he played Queen to h2 but
it seems like a weird place to put the
Queen but it comes with a very powerful
idea which you'll see h6 not nice - e5
and excellent square for the knight
now this Knight here doesn't really do
all that much Knight back to f6 and here
we have Queen back to f4 and now the
queen is on a very powerful square now
Knight to h5 is no longer an idea
because the Queen both Queen and Knight
are attacking the f7 pawn so b5 here
ding already starts pushing his Queen
side pawns as both players have
developed all of their pieces
dink-dink has a pawn majority here on
the Queen side two points to one and
shark has a powerful center here so both
of them have to play with what they have
rook to e3 preparing for a nice I mean a
nice rock lift preparing ideas maybe
rope to f3 or rook to g3 in the future
we have rook to c7 and now nice to d3
rock to c7 again give
additional protection to the f7 pawn now
ideas like a roof to g3 are no longer
possible not simply nice to h5 attack
the Queen and the rook and the f7 point
is protected by the rook on c7 so after
up to c7 night to d3 preparing to
Riemann over that night to c5 so dink
quickly plays rook to c3 before the
knife comes to c5 and logs the C file
Knight to c5 now rook captures on e3
Queen captures on e3 and now Bishop to
c6 rook to c1 and now Queen to b6 again
giving protection to the bill to the
bishop on c6 and also preparing to push
the Queen side pawns
we have f3 solidifying that pawn on e4
rook to d8 and now King to f2 and here
dink pushes a5 he says you don't really
have anything here with white pieces I'm
just gonna push push my pawns on the
Queen side as I do have the advantage
here and you can't really do anything in
the center Mahmud arrow goes g4 now we
have a for attacking the bishop bishop -
see - and now nice to d7 Bishop to d3
now Knight captures on c5 rook captures
on c5 and now B for pushing the pawns
even further
Bishop to c4 giving protection to the B
3 square Bishop to d7 now not allowing
this Bishop to become a target and also
adding more protection here to the e6
square this mission will become a very
very important defensive piece in the
future
first g5h captures on g5 Queen captures
on g5 and now Bishop - I ate b3
immediately was possible without the
dismissal to e8 move but there's really
nothing white can do here or push
anything so first ding improves the
position and only then will he push me 3
we have Queen to e7 now now comes b3
a capture some b3 and now a 3 creating a
very powerful passed pawn before now so
the bishop is now eyeing the a2 square
but now rook to e8 and now point to a2
is a terrible threat here you don't
really you don't really have a great
move
for white here mama dada fried d5 d5
would the idea that after a two which is
what Dean played now being is basically
offering this point here for example
Bishop captures and of course you can't
capture the bishop with the rook because
your Bishop on e8 is hanging but simply
Queen captures on before wins the game
for black why does it well the rockin c5
is pinned your your next move is gonna
definitely be rook to c8 attacking it
and there's really nothing for a white
to do here so after something like
Bishop to c4 getting the bishop out of
harm's way
now comes Rock to a1 and however hard to
believe black is lost here it doesn't
matter white doesn't have a move anymore
white player loses doesn't really matter
even capturing this Bishop with check
King h7 again white doesn't have a move
whatever you play you can maybe try and
give up this Bishop instead of something
but regardless black always says Queen
to e1 check King g2 and now Queen to g1
and this will be checkmate as the f1 and
the th pawn lock away the king
so after this a to Madero tried D
captures on e6 here being calculates
precisely he brings another queen into
the game but it was a it was not that
simple to calculate everything but he
was very successful in doing so he
captures on f7 would check pawn captures
and now Bishop captures on f7 would
check Queen captures isn't isn't any
better we have king to h7 and now Queen
to h4 check so the bishop is guarding
the g8 and the g6 square the King can't
go anywhere
Queen to h6 blocking and now rook to h5
and this will be a completely winning
position for white if it weren't for the
fact that dink has another Queen on a1
which is very unfortunate for mommy Yara
but it is as it is
so here it's things move and you do have
to play precisely to win this game you
could maybe blunder the game by maybe
playing Queen to d4 check King to g2 and
then trying to figure out a win here for
black but
dink doesn't go for anything like this
immediately plays Queen to ASA
this comes with check and this is the
strongest move as it picks up the bishop
on f7 so after this Queen to a7 move
mama D are resigned the game what would
follow Kim G to Queen captures and now
white really doesn't have anything here
you do have to kind of capture the Queen
you can't allow black to have two Queens
on the board rock captures pawn captures
and now white black is simply up a whole
rook regardless of there being so many
pawns on white side it's it's pointless
to play this so yeah after after this
Queen to a7 check
Medea resigned and the curse is
officially broken being Liron won his
first game in the candidates tournament
and interestingly I better show it
before before I forget here are the
results after the after 12 rounds of the
candidates tournament you have Kerrigan
in first place with 7 points and Caruana
in second place with also 7 points
because the main criteria if there's a
tie break is is the encounter between
the two of them so Kara can wonder
encounter and so it's cocaine who will
take first place if they will tie at the
end of the tournament mama Dee are up
now in third place with six and a half
but there's also a type Gary shook also
with six and a half and the ding Lear
and also with six and a half after
beating mama Dee are of in this game so
mama dinner also had an excellent chance
here if he if he won this game against
England then he would have seven and a
half points but unfortunately being
played an excellent game and now created
chances for everyone so now pretty much
everyone has an opportunity to win the
candidates you know maybe
okay maybe not Kramnik that that would
be I don't know I don't know if that
would be even possible all of the
leading players would have to lose all
of their games which I don't think it's
possible but you know Bingley shook mama
D ro Quran and Kirk in all all five of
them have excellent chances of winning
the tournament and it's interesting
after 12 rounds now it's only Dingley
Ron who is still undefeated in this
tournament and not all the games were
drawn he won this game so definitely a
an excellent performance he's at
his railing performance is not 20 818
which I mean of course all of the
players are rated around 2800 but still
you know an excellent showing and I did
prepare the the pairings for the next
round here are the parents for round 13
we have ma media or vs Greece shock also
a game that could decide the outcome of
the candidates tournament Dingley rand
versus Kramnik so the if dink wants the
win he does have to push with the white
pieces against Grambling definitely
romney doesn't really have a chance of
winning but maybe that's the reason
while he will be so successful in
playing this game he may be there there
will be no pressure he has the black
pieces he can just wait for them to push
and maybe punish him I will we have a
very interesting game then he we have
Wesley with the white pieces against
kurakin it's can concur I can do
something here with the black pieces not
not likely but you know anything can
happen I guess and then Khurana versus
Iranian Iranian drew drew his game today
so he did stop the bleeding but Caruana
will definitely try to do something with
the white pieces in that game against
levin so yeah those those were the
pairings and the results after after
round 12 I do hope you enjoyed that and
I do hope you enjoyed this game once
again thanks to Niki we do have photos
from every round of this tournament as
usual all of the links to our social
media pages will be in the description
below feel free to follow her if you
enjoy some chest photography and
photography in general and yeah as usual
you can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon
probably would not we'll have to see
maybe maybe tomorrow we do have time for
one towel versus Botvinnik game but
we'll see either way thank you all and
have have an excellent Saturday and the
rest of the weekend